well welcome Michael it's been it's been
fabulous having you here in the Seattle
region I should say we had you guys know
the town hall with Aaron Roth your
co-author of the new book the ethical
logarithm and just now we had you at the
Microsoft Research distinguished AI
lecture and a lot of fun I know a great
engagement with the audience we're gonna
start by saying that I've always admired
the constellation of topics that you
you've explored your set of interests
I'm curious how you got to where you are
you know going back a little bit into
your maybe high school undergraduate
days and and what's your path like and
how do you describe yeah I guess in many
ways my path was a little bit
untraditional compared to kind of our
peers in high school I was a pretty
diffident math student I didn't find it
very interesting I would often slack off
I would you know make up for a run of
bad quiz scores by you know kind of
suddenly panicking and kind of evening
them things out and in high school I was
um the topic I was really most excited
about was kind of English and writing
and journalism so I did a lot of kind of
local journalism for the San Diego
newspaper and the neighborhood I lived
this sort of thing
and so when I started you know I started
becoming more interested in math and
science towards the end of high school
but started college as an English major
and you know they pretty quickly
realized that I decided to major in
English because I wanted to write and I
became they came to think that it was
gonna teach me how to read more than it
was gonna teach me how to write I mean
at that same time my math and computer
science classes started to become much
more interesting you know I was you know
beginning to Berkeley and that was kind
of in the first wave of computer science
being kind of a popular major it was
kind of increasing awareness not the
frenzy that we have today but but
certainly once once the I sort of saw
the more
creative side of math like proving
things or the creative side of computer
science like building stuff then at some
point I think I never looked back and
see what it's a grad school I went to
grad school at Harvard and I went
straight from undergrad and that was a
bit of a culture shock because I'm a
native Californian and I'd never lived
on the East Coast before so I had to
adapt to that and I also at the time
Harvard was a much smaller Department
live mathematics but it was actually
computer science by that yeah it was by
that time and I really went primarily
you know in the hopes of working with
one particular advisor which was less
valiant but I do remember feeling you
know the first year of grad school kind
of narrowed and claustrophobic because
I'd gone from this you know huge state
school where I did you know continued to
take classes in the humanities
throughout my entire time - suddenly you
know taking only computer science
classes and only being around computer
science people for most of each day and
so that that was sort of an adjustment
that I had to make that probably every
doctoral student has to make early on
career did you know less his work did
you know you what to do computational
learning theory that I did and that's
more or less what I went there to work
on so I think you know by by late
college I knew that I was attracted to
the more theoretical algorithmic
mathematical side of computer science at
that time but I also knew that I wasn't
especially interested in a lot of the
traditional you know optimization style
problems that were kind of the bread and
butter of theoretical computer science
at that time you know sort of either you
know complexity theory which I found
very interesting but it's a hard field
but but even the algorithmic side at
that time you know we weren't at that
kind of computational lens phase anymore
of computer science and theoretical
computer science in particular still
studied optimization problems like
traveling salesman and graph coloring
and you know all great classical stuff
but I knew that somehow I wasn't as
interested in that as in taking that
same way of thinking and applying it to
less tradition
topics and so when I learned about
valiance work in in learning which was
quite new at that time I think his first
paper came out and maybe you know I
graduated Berkeley in 85 and the first
paper was maybe 82 or 83 it was a
revelation to me I sort of thought wow
you know yes you could take these same
ways of thinking these same algorithmic
tools and think about like a natural
phenomenon like noir learning and that I
found very appealing and so decided to
roll the dice and maybe go to a smaller
department than I might have in order to
hope to work with him and that that
worked out well in the end how did you
go from your your focus on on the
compositional learning theory into the
game theoretic world and it's the
algorithmic game theory how did that
yeah you know it's funny I'll admit that
maybe I'm just not sufficiently
reflective but I'd like to claim that
there was sort of some grand plan in my
mind connections between these topics
and and really I wish I could because
you know there was this period where I
just became interested in game theory
there wasn't really such a thing as
algorithmic game theory at the time
there weren't any known connections at
that time between you know learning
theory and game theory or machine
learning and game theory and so the you
know this was just some other interest
that I had that I thought like oh you
know somehow at some aesthetic level
these things seem the same to me like
the you know the sort of level of
sophistication of the mathematical
arguments the sort of focus on you know
models that have strong foundations but
that might be applicable to real-world
situations and so I don't know if like a
decade I just kind of carried these
interests separately and then at some
point you know it didn't seem so weird
anymore to have these two interests and
there were other people working on them
as well I'd like to say that like oh I
plan for that convergence to happen or
saw it coming it was really just two
different interests and I think more
generally you know one of the reasons I
even though I've worked on a lot of
different topics some of which are not
considered primarily the
you know in the purview of computer
science per se I always think of myself
as a computer scientist first and
foremost in the sense of you know of of
V in the appear Aeolus sense of
computer science so my you know my view
of computer science is that one of the
greatest things about the field is that
collectively computer scientists don't
really seem to pay much attention to
disciplinary boundaries right so the AI
community in particular is you know
right guilty as charged yeah so it's
like you know rife with examples of
where we waded into some topic and
started you know you know doing research
and writing papers in it and then you
know we discover like oh you know what
you call reinforcement learning is
called like you know learning and
control theory and it's been around
since like the 40's and and so we have
this habitus computer scientists I think
of you know if something's interesting
wading into it embarrassing ourselves
for some amount of time but in the
specific case of reinforcement learning
even though there was some rediscovery
of the wheel eventually computer
scientists made like truly novel
contributions that needed to be made
from people with an algorithmic
computational perspective no it's a view
of your game theoretic work you you very
interesting in a direction you'd of into
behavioral studies with human beings to
tell more about where that came from
miss Amanda some of the studies yeah
yeah so at Penn I teach and I have now
for many years a large undergraduate
survey class called Network life which
is um you know this is kind of a I
wouldn't have described it this way at
the beat when I first developed it
because these terms didn't exist but
it's kind of a survey class on network
science on sort of the science of social
networks and you know how influence or
content spread in a social network and
and also you know quite a bit on on
computational social sciences we would
call it more broadly and so I you know I
have fun with this class it's sort of a
class I designed to
also dovetail with my current research
interest rather than you know kind of
teaching a textbook subject out of the
classic textbook but but to make things
realize I sort of started doing these
in-class experiments in you know kind of
collective behavior and strategic
interaction and networked some things I
suppose some examples of things you did
so I think you know like one of the
things I do in the first day of class is
I say like you know just to sort of
illustrate these kind of six degrees of
separation ideas as I say okay everybody
look around the room and and basically
consider yourself to be you know in a
network and your neighbors in the
network or anybody that you see in this
room that you know like you've met them
before in person okay
and so you know everybody looks around
and then I say and then I toss a tennis
ball to somebody and I say okay your
goal is to get the tennis ball to that
person in the back left of the
auditorium but you everybody can only
like throw the tennis ball to somebody
that they know in the class okay and
sometimes I ask the person at the back
of the room to give a little information
about themselves like their hometown in
their major but basically people try to
toss the tennis ball around and we see
how many hops it takes for the tennis
ball to get there and it always gets
there and then and then we say like okay
that took you know four hops is that
good or bad
how could we know and then I say like
well one way we could know is you know
by that I'm doing a crowdsource
breadth-first search so what I do is I
say like okay the first person I get the
tennis ball you stand up okay
now anybody who knows this person stand
up okay okay and then I say now anybody
who knows anybody who's standing stand
up and we just keep doing this in
synchronized ways and we see how many
waves of standing it takes to get the
person in the back of the auditorium and
that's the shortest path distance right
so this is the kind of thing I was doing
I have to say that you know Yuri let's
give a connected messenger connections
by its acquaintances graph we were just
stunned to see 6.6 degrees for messenger
yes banning the planet many years like I
saw in that paper in this particular
class I think sort of the Facebook four
degrees
operation paper that was yes later but
so you know it's kind of doing these
in-class demos that were fun and
interesting and I thought oh you know I
could try to do this in a more
controlled laboratory setting and so
actually with since Ori who's here at
Microsoft Research Redmond and is a
close friend and colleague he was in
grad student at that time and had this I
think a similar kind of you know
devil-may-care attitude about research
like you know it's wacky we know nothing
about this what the hell let's try it
and so we designed laboratory
experiments in human subject graph
coloring so what we did is we brought
like a bunch of students from the class
into a workstation a lab full of
workstations I couldn't think like less
than 40 workstations and we you know
built and designed software that
basically gave a GUI where you had you
know you or a vertex represented in the
middle of the screen you saw your
neighbors in that network and the edges
between their neighbors your so-called
like local or ego Network and there was
like a an action bar at the bottom where
you had to choose what color to pick to
be your vertex and you'd be able to see
the color of your vertices your
neighbors in real time and so you know I
was trying to see in small you know in
on small networks of our design that the
students didn't know about first of all
could people do this stuff at all right
you know could they in a short amount of
time actually coordinate to find a
proper solution to the graph coloring
problem in a you know a few minutes or
so and secondarily if they are able to
do that can how does network structure
matter or there's certain types of
network structure that are behaviorally
more favorable to finding a solution
quickly and others that are more
difficult and you know what can we say
about why that might be and so we did
this and it was kind of wacky and you
know we had no idea where to send this
kind of work and I was you know already
quite friendly at that time with
in watts who was at MSR New York for
many years but has now joined us on the
Penn faculty and you know he'd done you
know human subject work and was a leader
in network science already at the time
he says like oh you know you know in his
great Australian accent yeah you should
you should stand that's a science and
I'm like okay you know and and he you
know and so it took his advice and he
gave us some good like expository advice
for us and you know it got in and and
it's at that point with if we come back
to decide like okay was this sort of a
one-off you know kind of almost like a
scientific joke or are we serious about
these kinds of questions and I decided I
was serious about them and so this led
to a long string of behavioral work over
like a 10-year period in which we you
know played around with different tasks
including ones that are related to kind
of influence in voting decisions and a
bunch of other problems and also you
know explored the network structures and
it was a it was fascinating work I
learned a lot from it
still feels a little bit wacky to me but
I'm glad I did it no but I think it's
it's helped to define a whole paradigm
of effort and hopefully it'll it's it's
it's inspired many other studies like
this yeah when I mean speaking honestly
about that work I enjoyed it greatly and
often find myself thinking about
behavioral human subject work and we've
been doing a little bit of it in in sort
of fairness areas more recently one of
the reasons I kind of deliberately
stopped that line of work was that you
know first of all that line of work gave
me tremendous respect for people that do
careful human subject work and I learned
a lot from many such people although all
of the errors are mine as the cliche
goes but one of the things I realized at
some point is just like the design space
that we were considering where you know
your design space includes all of the
possible networks that you could impose
on the experiment and all of the
possible distributed behavioral tasks
that you could ask subjects you know
early on we had to decide like okay we
have these interesting results on
coloring do we now like go do
on coloring and do ever more refined
experiments on coloring or do we kind of
do more of a shotgun approach and I kind
of felt like well this is such an
unpopulated landscape that really it
would be more fun and serve science
better to take the shotgun approach for
a while but then after 10 years of doing
it I was just kind of like you know this
is never ending right I could do nothing
but these kinds of experiments would the
rest of my career and there would be no
clear stopping point and on the other
hand when I thought about like the deep
dive into one particular task and let's
say type of network structure you know
is reminded by the extensive literature
let's say in behavioral game theory on
you know repeated prisoner's dilemma or
the ultimatum game where the same
experiment has been run hundreds or
thousands of times with slightly
different variations in different
cultures etc etc and I was just like
that's not for me either and so my kind
of you know at least temporarily retired
from that particular line of work it's
great to have you with us for the
Microsoft AI distinguished lecture but
coincidentally you're also on a book
tour and I just finished your your
fabulous book the ethical algorithm and
first let me ask you what possessed you
to write a book with with your colleague
Aaron Roth yeah I mean I think it was
the combination of the rising societal
awareness of the negative consequences
of large-scale algorithmic decision
making including that kind of
perpetuated by machine learning and the
standard machine learning pipeline you
know things like models predictive
models that are discriminatory by race
or by gender or the leaked private
information from the training set these
sorts of things so we've kind of watched
with everybody else the increased media
reports about these things and the
popular books that were written on these
topics on the one quite negative thing
yeah most of them I think kind of just
you know correctly highlighting the
problem and telling
people this is being done with your data
and these are the bad things that can
happen to people including yourself from
the use of that data so so we kind of
you know like everybody else saw that
this could happen and on the other hand
Aaron on IR you know both for the last
five years or so have been primarily
working on how you would design
algorithms to avoid or at least reduce
these kinds of harms in the first place
so as opposed to having well-defined
algorithms that are simple visible the
food implementers dinner when their
goals like minimize cost right in their
use expect or average cost thinking
about actually enhancing them extending
them algorithmically to to address some
of the concerns rather than bringing in
lawyers and and necessarily or you know
sort of regulatory activity to control
them that's right I mean you know we
also believe that regulatory and legal
approaches and improvements are needed
as well but you know first of all those
are slow and also that by definition
they're sort of after the fact right you
know so when the FTC finds Facebook for
some you know privacy violation it's
happened already and here is the
punishment for that thing okay so these
kinds of approaches are both slow and
they tend to be after the fact now
sometimes you know things need to be
slow and they need to be after the fact
but as scientists we also know like
demonstrable ways that we could make our
algorithms better from a social
perspective so instead of just
minimizing the error I could you know
minimize the error under the constraint
that you know the rate at which I'm
falsely rejecting women for loans is not
radically higher than the rate at which
I'm rejecting men's for loan right we
know scientifically how to write that
problem down and we know algorithms for
solving that problem and so you know
getting back to the impetus for writing
the book we really felt that there was a
need for a book that kind of followed in
the steps of books that
came before us that pointed out what the
problems were and largely suggested the
kind of regulatory and legal solutions
that you suggested we felt there was
room for a book that said hey you know
while you're waiting for that here are
things that you know we and companies
and individuals you know in scientists
and engineers could change about our
algorithms right now and you know maybe
not fix all these problems but at least
improve them and put like the discussion
of them on a scientific basis rather
than kind of an ad-hoc basis and so
that's why we wrote the book
what's your your sense for the limits of
how far we might go let's say let's tell
with fairness right right now on the
algorithmic front we have so many
possible choices and interpretations it
seems that there is going to be some
notion of in whose eyes do we behold the
fairness and I I wrestle myself at times
looking at these very crisp definitions
and as fabulous to see these these
approaches incrementing on the prior
more naive approach this per goal
addressing some of the concerns for
example with obvious unfair or biased
inferences but where do we see choices
and process going when it comes to
figuring out which one to apply in
reality yeah so particular configuration
yeah so we've discussed this at some
length in the book and in particular you
know as you know most of the definitions
of fairness that have been proposed in
the algorithmic literature require one
to first sort of specify who you're
worried about being harmed by a decision
making process algorithm or human right
and and then what could what would
constitute harm to that group and then
you're in business to sort of say like
okay you know let's say you're using
machine learning learn a model that
tries to minimize the error but make
sure that it obeys this fairness
constraint that we've written down and
as if you
to the you know one qualitative problem
with this area is that you know there's
lots of different groups I could protect
and lots of different mathematical
definitions of fairness that I could
specify and we already know
unfortunately that that some of these
combinations are incompatible with each
other so it literally might be that you
have a data set yeah that faces you with
the problem that if I you know asked for
more racial fairness of some particular
variety the only way I can get it is at
the expense of increased gender
unfairness okay and so in all these
different you know implementation of
social norms and algorithms there's
always gonna be this trade-off between
the social norm and accuracy in fairness
it's even worse it's like even ignoring
accuracy asking for more of one type of
fairness that you want might mean that
you have to have a savannah fight so I
guess my reflection has been as we get
more transparent and clear thinking
about the different definitions and how
to precisely execute the goals in our
algorithms there's a framing of a really
hard discussion that needs to happen
somewhere when it comes to the
applications that we as a society I
think have not figured out how to
actually execute on that's exactly right
I think and the you know the way I might
put that is that especially in the
instance of album make fairness I think
one of the main virtues of the science
is that it can identify what the really
hard problems are what the problems are
that really need to be worked out by
human organizations and society and you
might think like okay well so what's
what's science good for if it what it
does is identify you know the hard
problems that science can't can't solve
I mean I think this is exactly one of
the values of science in general right
which is that if you look sort of before
the flurry of work on differential
privacy on algorithmic fairness there
was confusion about what part of this
was hard and
and you know what what what can be
solved scientifically and
algorithmically and what are the parts
that like really algorithms can't do
that for you no matter how hard you work
on them you know somebody has to make
the decision about whether we're going
to trade off racial fairness and gender
fairness and by how much and at what
cost to accuracy so just just to be
clear I know it's clear to you but just
for the viewers right our book and the
research fields that we are representing
in no way suggests that algorithms
should themselves decide what fairness
or privacy means you know that we view
as something that remains firmly in the
social and human domain but you know
until all this flurry of work on fade
topics I think you know we really didn't
have a clear idea of what the boundary
was between science and society and I
think you know in my view we're
discovering that science can do quite a
lot algorithmically but it can also just
show us what it can't do in a way that
we didn't know before and and so our
thinking on these topics was just fuzzy
before and now it's becoming crisper
they just apply the clarifying lens to
figure out where we now know it's a
social societal people-oriented set of
questions that need to be decided right
and and and and to ask by whom you know
and before it wasn't so clear as to what
was going on and so the algorithmic
perspective really helps us with that
they border yeah and I find it you know
I think one of our our goals for the
book is you know I mean of course we
would love it if this became you know
next summer's Hamptons Beach read but
but you know I think more realistically
we're hoping that this book can kind of
lay out the landscape that we're talking
about for kind of a core audience that
includes people like regulators
policymakers social workers legal
organizations and the like because and I
think again one of the motivations in
writing the book was as I started
talking to people from you know those
parts of the world more in just the
course of the research that we're doing
I realized you know these are
are very smart people but they but to
them sort of the entire like algorithm
machine learning AI pipeline the whole
thing is this black box and you know the
I felt like I was getting comments of
the kind of like well this is just so
complicated nobody can understand any
piece of it whatsoever and you know
that's not true we understand many parts
of this pipeline extremely well and many
you know many parts of these this
pipeline have very very well founded
scientific principles that train smart
people are applying and in some cases it
might be those very principles which are
the problem right so it's just sort of
you know if you optimize just for
accuracy you shouldn't expect for free
to get fairness of some kind right you
can't see a follow-on book that starts
with the the foundations laid out upon
the principles that you write so
eloquently about and it's all about
let's just take a few data sets and a
few trade-offs and reason through how
you think about the social aspects of
these decisions yeah kind of a deeper
dive if you like but I'm not put on the
social societal side a process side
looking at how we might even begin as a
society even considering the
governmental agency mechanisms we have
in place right now and and social
societal civil society feedback
mechanisms how do you actually do it
yeah I mean that's a great suggestion
you know my first reaction to it is that
Michael you Michael don't be pessimistic
wait no I can think of a lot of people
that I would like to write such a book I
mean I think you know maybe a little bit
more to the point I think you know if
people like Aaron and I were to write
that book we would want like
collaborators on these case studies
because you know in particular these
decisions about you know whether it's
worth trading off this type of fairness
for that type of fairness or you know
this type of fairness for this much less
accuracy these need to be very domain
dependent you know decisions they in the
stakes matter it
whether you're you know making decisions
that influence people's parole decisions
versus what ads to show them and so you
you know you want to have people that
really unusual
I have to say that speaking of of the
real world it's even Messier the
realities in even much messier as we all
know that even the the clarified worlds
that we come up with separating out the
social from the algorithmic on the
partnership on I I bored we had a
meeting in Philadelphia your hometown
recently where we sat with a number of
officials from the criminal justice
system in Philadelphia which has
particularly traditionally has had high
incarceration rates and in the context
of risk scores used for recidivism heard
about the reality of how things really
work with bail and incarceration and
arrests and it seems so complicated and
messy that even the the the clarified
views we have when we think about these
challenges challenges in our abstract
abstract inversions of these problems
are way different
so yeah in a different metropolitan area
you know I'm you know on a sort of an
oversight or advisory panel for a city
that's basically trying to revise its
risk assessment models and is
particularly concerned with you know
fairness and you know again it has not
made me an expert by any stretch of the
imagination but you know do you just
realize that like well if you think
about you know building a model to
predict failure to appear so somebody's
been arrested they have a court date you
have to decide whether or to like keep
them incarcerated until that appearance
date or release them on bail and how
much or under what restrictions and
things like this and then you know you
kind of get it all into all this stuff
that's just not in the data at all
sort of like you know well you know
actually if somebody is working two jobs
then you know appearing in court at this
specific time might really actually
cause them to lose that job right there
might just be in a job where there's
zero tolerance for and so you know you
know you you suddenly realize okay you
know yes there is this data set and you
want to use this data set to build an
accurate predictive model you know even
under the canoe with the constraint of
fairness so you're trying to do the
right thing but then you learn like okay
actually things are really complicated
and people might fail to appear patients
outside the neuron completely legitimate
and you're quite sympathetic to that
leave no trace in the data whatsoever
and therefore you know aren't kind of
represented or spoken for in your
algorithm and so you know it's hard
right yeah
it's sobering I love the section of your
book where you take the algorithmic lens
and put it on the endeavour of science
itself it's a fabulous chapter like to
discuss that more with you I think to a
first approximation the reproducibility
crisis which has you know play certain
parts of like the social and
psychological sciences and also the food
science area a way that it goes further
than that no I am too but these are the
ones I think that have been the most
publicized right so by the way we know
in writing this book we were kind of we
didn't we debated like whether to name
names of people that you know had had
been kind of caught up in this kind of
scientific scandal and ended up doing so
but also but scandal implies that
there's that it was done with knowledge
in some cases it seems like it was in
some cases it wasn't but the but just to
be clear like the for the viewers like
the types of problem we're discussing
here I think at some high level are
versions of overfitting or more
precisely of kind of communal
overfitting and so the problem is you
know I gather some data set and I'm
interested in like okay is
the case that I don't know what's
drinking more red wine improves your
lifespan for instance right and so I
gather a large sample of people and I
know about their red wine drinking
habits and I know how long they lived
and you know maybe I have a hypothesis
that you know that that it makes you
live longer and so I I look at that data
so now that's not really supported I
can't
you know the p-value is too big oh but I
noticed some other interesting and thing
in the data while I'm looking at this
hypothesis and so I say like oh well you
know let me let me on the same data set
let me test that hypothesis and that
doesn't quite work out and then I do
this right and you know one technical
point that we try to convey in the book
is that you know it's not when you're
doing this adaptive data analysis and
you know your next hypothesis or
experiment is on the same data set by
conditioned on everything you've tried
so far you don't just have to correct
for the number of things that you've
tried so far you have to correct for all
of the things you might have tried under
all the possible outcomes of the thing
you've tried and just to make this
concrete like we start the chapter off
with a non-scientific example we say
like you know suppose you get an email
one day that says like oh hey I've got a
stock tip for you you know this
particular stock is gonna go up tomorrow
okay and you know you ignore it but you
check and the stock goes up and then you
get another email the next day that says
it's gonna go up again and it goes up
again and then the third day it says
it's gonna go down and it goes down and
sort of after 10 tries in a row you
think like okay this person either knows
this company very well or has inside
information or is a financial genius and
so you agree to pay them some upfront
fee for further stock tips that then are
no better than random guessing and of
course the scam that went on right is
this person on the first day sent a
million emails and to half of the people
they said it's gonna go up and happen
it's gonna go down on the half they were
wrong they just give up and don't send
them another email again and on the half
they were right they then branch again
and they're building like a complete
binary tree of depth 10 let's say
sometimes somebody thinks they're really
smart yeah and so you happen to be on
that one you know you didn't see all the
other email yes as far as you're
concerned you're only a
appearances this 10 correct predictions
in a row and it's not enough of course
to sort of correct that like for 10
things that we're done you need to
correct for the 2 to the 10th things
that you didn't see ok so this is kind
of the problem and one might seriously
worry that we are engaged collectively
in this kind of exercise in the machine
learning community why because now
there's not just one email scammer but
there's hundreds and thousands of us
running experiments on shared data sets
and we're also reading each other's
papers so I see you know your improved
error rates on some benchmark data set
with somehow with some particular with
some particular algorithmic modeling
innovation and I say like oh that's a
good idea I like Eric's idea we're gonna
like you know explore a refinement or
variation of it and we try like 10
things which seems like a modest number
and then the eleven thing improves on
your error rate and that gets published
and of course you know if we tried
submitting to the top conferences or
journals one of the ten things that we
try to improve on your method and it
didn't work and our abstract is like oh
you know we take Horvitz as recent
method and we try this variation and
achieve worse error rates it will not be
getting published right so the
publishing mechanism is kind of like the
filtering in the emails game you know
you're not unaware of how many things
were tried and that weren't successful
you only hear about the winners okay so
this is a recipe for our communally
overfitting it's such an important
problem of our time and you know reap
you know and right and it's really you
know this could have happened in any era
but especially in the era of data-driven
science and I think machine learning is
kind of the epitome of data-driven
science and it's also not just that it's
like we're it's not even just the
journals being selective for positive
results and therefore kind of
perpetuating a bias like we're kind of
doing it to ourselves in the form of
these competitions right where we say
okay everybody here's the training set
but we want you to have some sense of
progress so you can upload
model like once a week and will just
tell you what your error on the test set
is also right so it allows us to kind of
all exfiltrate and you know if we don't
know how many of us are trying this and
the exfiltration is sort of too precise
and telling us exact error rates then
we're essentially without any one of us
misbehaving or realizing it we are
collectively performing some kind of
gradient descent on the test data not on
the training data and so we talked about
this and kind of view it from kind of a
game theoretic viewpoint and then we you
know discuss you know different types of
solutions that are proposed there was
there's the whole pre-registration
movement which is one solution but it's
a very onerous solution it you know at a
high level it requires before you gather
any data you need to commit to what your
hypothesis is you then go gather the
data and you register this on like a
official website you then go gather the
data you are allowed to test that one
thing and report the outcome and then
you need to burn that data set forever
right not only can you not use it nobody
else can use it either okay so our view
is that yes this is some solution that
if you know really enacted at scale
would greatly set back legitimate
scientific research you know at the
benefit of kind of eradicating this kind
of P hat another trade-off and you know
it's early days but it does seem like
there are other methods that are more
algorithmic that I think are much more
appealing and we discuss those and
interestingly many of those are related
technically to differential privacy
you've been very successful Michael in
your life and you when I say success I
mean in in all senses of the word
particularly your happiness and joy with
what you do I know also with your family
life from some of what I know about your
you personally what what are some ideas
or or insights or recommendations to
young people about career yeah it's a
good question
so you know again as per questions and
room you've asked earlier in remarks you
know I've never been one of these people
that's had a ten-year plan and I mind it
when people you know I've met people
before not necessarily scientists but I
just met people that say like well I've
got you know my wife Kim and I at one
point met I think it was like a realtor
that was was showing us places and you
know this guy said like young guy says
I've got like a one-year plan a
five-year plan and a ten-year plan I'm
like wow you know I can you plan to get
out of real estate
and you know when I look back at my
career
first of all Menem my overwhelming
sentiment is one of gratitude I feel
very lucky to be where I am and feel
that you know kind of you know kind of
society came my way and you know so you
know and I think I might have written
one of the first if not the first
dissertation with the word machine
learning in the title it was certainly
one of the earliest and you know at that
time as you know machine learning was
kind of this neglected corner of AI
right and there's very little activity
in it and everything was wide open and
you know the field has been tremendously
successful and I'd like to think that I
contributed something to that but if I'm
honest with myself I think like well
really the rise of the consumer internet
kind of moved machine learning and AI
from being an important valuable
scientific tool with fascinating
research going on into it into something
that was like right in the middle of
society okay and and you know I I'm not
responsible for that even though I've
you know greatly benefited in my career
from that trend so a lot of it was sort
of you know being in the right place at
the right time I think the the the
strongest piece of advice I have for for
certainly for you know young researchers
is to just relentlessly follow your
interests and to ignore disciplinary
boundaries and don't think of yourself
as you know don't think of yourself as
anything don't think of yourself you
know
I was trained as a theoretical computer
scientist I consider myself a
card-carrying member of that community
and forever shapes my view of you know
not just algorithmic problems but the
world more generally but I you know I
don't require you know sort of only
doing theory work and you know when I
became interested in game theory
I just wanted to study it and learn more
about it and do research in it some of
which is better than others right and so
I think to me you know I I can't imagine
a more burdensome life than doing
research trying to do research in a
topic that you're not interested in
right sort of like in some ways the
world of research encompasses like the
extreme of the extremes of you know
professional despair and euphoria
because if you're doing something that
you're really interested in you really
love then it really is like you know
it's that oh my god I can't believe I'm
paid to do this whereas you know even if
you're paid to do it and you're trying
to be creative and original in a topic
that you're not interested I cannot
imagine a harder thing so you know in my
own career I just you know what I was
interested in something I studied it I
did research in it until I felt like I
was less interested in it or didn't have
as much to contribute and then I just
you know moved on and I think that's you
know if you can execute on that you know
that's that that's is like the only kind
of generalizable principle I think I can
take you know if I can talk about
specific pieces of work and why I did
them at the time but in terms of
generalizable advice it would be that
just keep moving keep working on what's
interesting to you don't worry about
what's interesting to you now how it
connects to what you did before and how
you're gonna explain why this makes
sense it's okay if it doesn't make sense
even in your head for long periods of
time or ever you know there's still
pieces of work I do where I think like
okay that was interesting I have no idea
how that fits in with my overall
research agenda it doesn't but my whole
research agenda
was created that way just by following
my nose to what I was curious about I'm
interested I could explain it as as all
the things that Michael Karns has been
interested in it's been great having you
hey Kyra I appreciate it